Julie Stout: Okay, I think we are set. So, hello again. My name is Julie Sao, and I'm here with John Hasse. I am… it is currently March 18th, 2026, and I'm currently in Bloomington, Indiana. And John, will you remind me where you're at?
John Hasse: I am in.
John Hasse: Alexandria, Virginia, Julie, and it's nice to see you again.
Julie Stout: Nice to see you again! We are here for part two of our oral history interviews, and this one's going to specifically touch on, the Dawson Gary Project. And so, without further ado, I can jump right in, if you're all good.
John Hasse: Sure.
Julie Stout: Awesome. So, starting, I guess, from the beginning, I want to know more about your first involvement. How did you first become connected to the Doris and Gary project, such as, like, when, where, and in what capacity?
John Hasse: I don't remember the exact month, but it was probably… Sometime in 1975,
John Hasse: Because I assume it was 1975.
John Hasse: when, Dawson would have… Submitted his application.
John Hasse: to the National Endowment for the Humanities to fund this project.
John Hasse: So, he probably identified the graduate students.
John Hasse: I think we were all doctoral students.
John Hasse: To join this project.
John Hasse: And then the money came through, and…
John Hasse: We went to Gary in…
John Hasse: June of 1976. We may have started in May.
John Hasse: And it may have gone into July?
John Hasse: It was… I believe we were on the ground about 6 weeks.
Julie Stout: Do you know why you were chosen for this project in particular, or why you showed interest in it, if at all?
John Hasse: Hmm.
John Hasse: Well, there weren't very many ethnomusicology.
John Hasse: Doctoral students at the time.
John Hasse: And… I think by then he knew I was interested in the music of Indiana.
John Hasse: I was doing a lot of research on ragtime music in Indiana, which…
John Hasse: merged into the history of jazz in Indiana.
John Hasse: And… I'm not sure why else, but I was, happy to be involved.
Julie Stout: When you read about the project itself, what was your initial, like, the grant proposal, if you even, like, looked at that or heard about it? What was your initial, like, thought on it? Was, like, were you intrigued by it? Were you…
Julie Stout: Yeah, just let me know your thoughts on that.
John Hasse: It's hard for me to… recollect or reconstruct my thoughts, but I probably was… A little surprised.
John Hasse: And, intrigued.
John Hasse: Because I believe he called it… the Calumet region.
John Hasse: Which, in northwest Indiana, is simply known as the region, or some people might say colloquially.
John Hasse: Del region.
John Hasse: And the only… time I'd ever given any real thought to Gary was…
John Hasse: in seeing the movie and the stage production, the Music Man, where this flim-flam,
John Hasse: The so-called music teacher, played by Robert Preston.
John Hasse: claimed to have a degree from the Gary Conservatory of Music in 06, which would be 2… 1906.
John Hasse: And, I…
John Hasse: don't know that I'd ever been through Gary, or I certainly had never stopped in Gary, so it was all gonna be a new experience to me.
Julie Stout: But one that I'm sure you learn from immensely, correct?
John Hasse: Oh, yes, and…
John Hasse: About that time, I discovered the short stories of Gene, J-E-A-N, Shepherd.
John Hasse: who was born in Hammond, Indiana, which is part of the region.
John Hasse: It adjoins Gary, And I… absolutely loved his stories. They were… just hilarious.
John Hasse: Based on his boyhood. And,
John Hasse: As a matter of fact, I recommended him so strongly to Professor Dawson.
John Hasse: That he brought him to the campus, and… A shepherd gave a…
John Hasse: An amazing performance. It must have lasted 2 hours.
John Hasse: Not one break, but… Not one note.
John Hasse: He just told these stories, one after another.
John Hasse: Everybody in the audience is spellbound.
John Hasse: And, so that… gave Gary some context for me, even though Hammond, at that time, was…
John Hasse: in a number of ways, different than Gary. Gary was very strongly African American.
John Hasse: And I don't know what the…
John Hasse: ethnic or racial makeup of Hammond was, but I don't think it was nearly as strongly black as Gary was.
Julie Stout: So it was a little, like, like, sliver that you were able to, like, connect to in… for the area and everything, yeah.
John Hasse: Yeah.
Julie Stout: In speaking with other individuals and other students that were also on the project, they noted that each student had their specialty, and I know since you were… you studied ethomusicology, music was a huge thing for you, along with Richard March, who also has a music, like, background.
Julie Stout: And I wanted to learn more about your roles and responsibilities on the project. What were your primary responsibilities, and how did they all, change, if at all, over time?
John Hasse: Sure.
John Hasse: Let's go back to the question about
John Hasse: how I became involved with the project.
John Hasse: If my chronology is correct.
John Hasse: I had taken a fieldwork class, In the folklore department.
John Hasse: And had decided to study.
John Hasse: the music of a black church in Bloomington.
John Hasse: Specifically, their gospel music.
John Hasse: And so… It's entirely possible or probable that
John Hasse: Dawson had heard about my fieldwork, In black gospel music, and…
John Hasse: Brought me into the project, too.
John Hasse: expand that fieldwork, if you would, to the northwest corner of Indiana.
John Hasse: I don't recall receiving… very specific instructions.
John Hasse: It's probably more like… go up to Gary, make some connections.
John Hasse: Visit black churches, And see what you can find and document.
John Hasse: It was pretty open-ended, as I recall.
John Hasse: And of course, in 1976, there was no internet.
John Hasse: There was no text messages, no mobile phones, so it was, a whole different…
John Hasse: Kettle of fish.
John Hasse: to, make context, I… I didn't know anybody in Gary.
John Hasse: So I went in there.
John Hasse: For me, it was Terra Incognita.
John Hasse: And, what I had to do was use the phone book a lot, particularly the Yellow Pages.
John Hasse: Looked up the section on churches, And started contacting churches.
John Hasse: And then sometimes, certain… certain of them were dead ends.
John Hasse: Church no longer existed, or…
John Hasse: The phone didn't work anymore. Some churches didn't have phones.
John Hasse: And then I got to know some people.
John Hasse: And they pointed me to others.
John Hasse: And, one of the others was a DJ, a long-time Gospel TJ.
John Hasse: and the Gary radio station, Her name was Vivian Carter.
John Hasse: And, much earlier. Well, let's see, this is 76.
John Hasse: At least 10 years earlier.
John Hasse: She had owned, or half-owned, I believe, VJ Records. V-E-E hyphen J-A-Y.
John Hasse: And for a while, they… VJ…
John Hasse: I had a license to put out a… an early Beatles LP.
John Hasse: So she was a noted personality.
John Hasse: And, I interviewed her, and…
John Hasse: She pointed me in some helpful directions. Everybody was… that I…
John Hasse: encountered was nice. I didn't meet anybody that wasn't nice to me, and I felt…
John Hasse: Very grateful to be, Welcome, Jen.
John Hasse: It could have been otherwise, you know, here's this…
John Hasse: Guy was very foreign to our community.
John Hasse: Knows very little about… The culture, and…
John Hasse: You know, so… but people got that I was a student. Some people wondered if I was a divinity student.
John Hasse: But they got that I was studying music, and…
John Hasse: Just about everybody was very accepting.
Julie Stout: Do you think your interest and knowledge of music opened doors for you into, like.
Julie Stout: Into, like, being welcomed to, like, welcomed by this community? Or, do you think it was something else?
John Hasse: Oh, definitely, and my bill?
Julie Stout: What are you?
John Hasse: To, play the piano.
John Hasse: I'd say was… really… Important.
John Hasse: 2… getting to know… the… gospel community.
John Hasse: One day, I… Visited a storefront.
John Hasse: Baptist Church.
John Hasse: And it literally was a storefront.
John Hasse: And the storefront windows, there were…
John Hasse: a big mural of Mary and Joseph.
John Hasse: Et cetera, and… Inside the… -
John Hasse: Excuse me, store.
John Hasse: There were about 6?
John Hasse: Sorry, I've got a frog in my throat. Six… let me grab a little water. 6 rows of chairs, folding chairs.
John Hasse: plain public in an Upright piano pushed up against the wall.
John Hasse: And I… Foolishly, Brought with me a still camera, A video camera.
John Hasse: And an audio tape recorder.
John Hasse: Instead of all three.
John Hasse: But the… Preacher?
John Hasse: Had told me in advance it would be okay.
John Hasse: To document the service in those ways.
John Hasse: And… So about halfway through the service.
John Hasse: He said, and we welcome today
John Hasse: a visitor, a student from Indiana University.
John Hasse: John Hassey, he motioned for me to stand up, and I…
John Hasse: I didn't want any, but I wanted to be…
John Hasse: I couldn't be inconspicuous, but I wasn't trying to be more conspicuous. I was… I felt shy and bashful and out of place.
John Hasse: He said, could be said.
John Hasse: You're a musician, aren't you?
John Hasse: And I didn't say anything.
John Hasse: How could he possibly know?
John Hasse: And he said, You're a piano player, aren't you?
John Hasse: And I go, no, no. He said.
John Hasse: Come on, get up, go play us a number.
John Hasse: I had to oblige, how could I say no?
John Hasse: So I went over to the piano and… Gave them my interpretation of… Amazing Grace.
John Hasse: And, I… Put in syncopations and some… Call and response cords.
John Hasse: And it was nothing like a good… Pianist…
John Hasse: who was a member of one of these churches could play, but, you know, I…
John Hasse: I did the best I could, and… as I played, I was…
John Hasse: very nervous and anxious, but I heard people,
John Hasse: Yeah.
John Hasse: And when I finished playing, the preachers said, Yes, hmm.
John Hasse: People be walking by the church this morning, hear that?
John Hasse: Good music coming out the window, and say, Nice Colored Boy playing.
John Hasse: What's up?
John Hasse: It was the highest compliment he could have paid me, and I…
John Hasse: I thought about that many times after that. It was…
John Hasse: It's so generous of him, and… affirming, and…
John Hasse: you know, as I, as in the…
John Hasse: black church I visited repeatedly in Bloomington.
John Hasse: Playing the piano, made all the difference in how well I was accepted.
John Hasse: They were… people were surprised that, you know.
John Hasse: First of all, they were surprised to see a white guy come into their churches, in most cases, because I suspect
John Hasse: few, if any, white people would go into these churches. Gary was…
John Hasse: Pretty segregated, not by law, but by custom at the time.
John Hasse: Especially in churches.
John Hasse: One church I… visited, I interviewed the pastor.
John Hasse: Reverend Roosevelt Rob Robinson, who is a…
John Hasse: Full-time Teamster and a part-time pastor.
John Hasse: This is a United Methodist Church.
John Hasse: And he told me that One day, A 15-year-old
John Hasse: Young man, who was black, walked in, and…
John Hasse: 30 of the white parishioners got up and left, just like that, in the middle of the service.
John Hasse: In the middle of the service, I asked him, he said, yes.
John Hasse: What did you say?
John Hasse: The preacher said, bye!
John Hasse: What else could I say?
John Hasse: Bye!
John Hasse: So, I met some…
John Hasse: memorable and wonderful people. It was a… it was a… it was a great experience. At the same time.
John Hasse: It was personally extremely difficult for me, because Just a few weeks prior.
John Hasse: My mother had died after a… Three-year harrowing fight against leukemia.
John Hasse: And my father had died 5 years earlier, so…
John Hasse: I'd lost my surviving parent, and… had no…
John Hasse: home to go home to for the rest of my life. It was gone.
John Hasse: So, I just plowed myself into my work in Gary, and… I… I think I worked…
John Hasse: Seven days a week, and… was either… Talking to people, or… recording performances,
John Hasse: Or making phone calls, you know, morning, noon, and night. There was, there was no…
John Hasse: I allowed myself no downtime. Didn't go to one movie, didn't go to one…
John Hasse: You know, or anything. It was just… Probably that…
John Hasse: Help my sanity at that point.
Julie Stout: it's… it's never easy dealing with loss of family members, but I'd like to think that
Julie Stout: The acceptance that you felt, probably, from the community in, like, those memorable moments for something that you hold so dear to your heart, like music, it must have, like, been…
Julie Stout: Yeah, very memorable for you.
John Hasse: It was.
Julie Stout: Yes.
Julie Stout: I definitely understand that.
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: The great… keep thinking on any of those memorable moments you might have, because there may be a question later down the line about more moments you can think of.
Julie Stout: But, taking us back a little bit to the beginning, but…
Julie Stout: what did you see were the project's aims at the start, and how did that evolve? Evolve either through your work or your work with Dorsen,
Julie Stout: Yeah. How would you see the projects?
Julie Stout: Ames evolved from the start to the end.
John Hasse: I don't know. If I don't…
John Hasse: I don't have a good memory of…
Julie Stout: No worries, yeah.
John Hasse: That, but, I…
John Hasse: it was… From my point of view, Essentially, a documenting project.
John Hasse: You could ask Tom Adler.
John Hasse: and go back to Richard Marcher if you wanted, but I… I believe that, Richard…
John Hasse: Documented, a lot of… Serbo-coration.
John Hasse: Life in… in the… In the Hammond region.
John Hasse: I remember… Going one time to a concert by the… Junior Tamboritsins.
John Hasse: And helping, him video record that, and… At this,
John Hasse: Serbian Hall, there was a very, very elderly man.
John Hasse: Who was playing the one-string Guzla.
John Hasse: A traditional folk instrument.
John Hasse: And he was going on and on and on.
John Hasse: Singing these long, epic songs. Back in Serbia.
John Hasse: Some could go on for hours.
John Hasse: So… maybe ancient, Type of storytelling.
John Hasse: And all the little kids were running around.
John Hasse: they weren't noticing him at all. I felt… I felt sorry for him, because hardly anybody was paying attention.
John Hasse: But, to me, it was a documenting project. Now, the… the…
John Hasse: Products that came out of it.
John Hasse: Of course, Dawson wrote another book.
John Hasse: He was a… good at writing and publishing books. Land of the Mill Rats.
John Hasse: There was a special issue of Indiana Folklore, the scholarly Journal.
John Hasse: There were articles in Folklore Forum, which was a graduate student Published.
John Hasse: academic journal.
John Hasse: I produced a half an hour documentary film called Gospel and Gary.
John Hasse: And I couldn't tell you the other products, but I believe there were some as well.
Julie Stout: Were there other collaborations between you and the other students, besides… I know you just said you were helping Richard with that specific, like, recording of the Tambrizza?
Julie Stout: Were there any other collaborations between you or the other students? Or Dawson?
John Hasse: Yes.
John Hasse: Could you pause for just a moment?
John Hasse: Or pause the recording.
Julie Stout: Okay, good.
John Hasse: There was a, another member of the so-called Gary Gang, Adrian Seward, A lovely, a lovely lady.
John Hasse: and we worked together a little bit. She helped me record…
John Hasse: Video record some of the, gospel performances, so…
John Hasse: She is credited as, one of the camera people.
John Hasse: At the end of that, half-hour video.
Julie Stout: Did she also have a music background, or was it just, like, passing interest, or how did that even come up?
John Hasse: I don't think… I don't remember if she had a music background, but she was on the folklore track.
John Hasse: And I was on the ethnomusicology track, and… I, got the money.
John Hasse: To hire a helicopter pilot in a helicopter.
John Hasse: And we went up over the city of Gary.
John Hasse: And I had my little Sony… portable camera.
John Hasse: Shot.
John Hasse: In black and white.
John Hasse: Because the tape was all black and white.
John Hasse: shot some, aerial views of Gary, and that… Begins the, the documentary video.
Julie Stout: A helicopter! Wow! That's awesome to, you were able to get those shots to start off your documentary and everything.
John Hasse: One of the most memorable things
John Hasse: was, Dawson took us to…
John Hasse: a plant of United States steel.
John Hasse: a U.S. steel mill or plant.
John Hasse: And, we went down, down, down in an elevator, and then we walked sideways, And there was…
John Hasse: There were big blast furnaces. I mean, these were enormous.
John Hasse: If memory serves, they were… Maybe 15, 20 feet wide.
John Hasse: And… The door to one of them was opened, and you looked inside, and it was just…
John Hasse: Red-hot fire, just… ablaze in there, I mean, just burning, burning. You could feel the heat.
John Hasse: 15, 20 feet back.
John Hasse: I mean, Isthma's… I wrote in a journal.
John Hasse: about it, said, this is a fiery vision of hell. It was… I'll never forget that.
Julie Stout: Did he take you students to that place to show… to show you more of, like, Gary itself, and, like, the infrastructure, or was it just, like, a field trip, per se, would you say?
John Hasse: Well, he thought we would benefit from.
Julie Stout: From seeing it.
John Hasse: The work that so many of our informants did.
John Hasse: Because that was the number one employer.
John Hasse: in Gary, and possibly the surrounding towns.
John Hasse: And, the mills, You could say, dominated the skyline, they dominated the economy, and they dominated employment.
Julie Stout: Did you take any footage of that, or was it mostly just to see it up close and personal to understand?
John Hasse: I don't recall taking any footage.
John Hasse: I had, and if I had… Still photos, they're long forgotten, but, maybe you'll be able to…
John Hasse: Cracked down all this, because it was, just an incredible treasure of…
John Hasse: Performances and interviews and, images.
Julie Stout: Did you record and take pictures and interview under the impression that this would be archived in the future, or was it…
Julie Stout: Did you know what the end goal was?
Julie Stout: From your work.
John Hasse: It's going to deposit all my…
John Hasse: documentation.
John Hasse: at IU, and so that was… that was my goal, to get… Is…
John Hasse: complete a picture as I could, given
John Hasse: I got there not knowing anybody.
John Hasse: And we had only so many days in Gary.
John Hasse: In the surrounding region.
John Hasse: To get as much… Captured, documented.
John Hasse: as I could, and then… It would be saved for posterity at IU.
Julie Stout: And here it is, still today, at IU and other campuses, even. People are still able to view them.
Julie Stout: So, I know you mentioned your memorable experiences and interviews you've had with people. I wanted to ask you a quick question about ethics and consent, which this is more of a modern thing that's come up in the past, decades or so, but…
Julie Stout: When you were, like, discussing or talking with your informants and other individuals.
Julie Stout: How were ethical considerations, like, handled, if at all? Like, were there, did you need permissions or confidentiality, with the people that you talked to?
John Hasse: I don't believe anybody told me anything.
John Hasse: That was confidential.
John Hasse: The closest to confidential I came was
John Hasse: I was invited to join a prayer meeting.
John Hasse: when… Late afternoon.
John Hasse: Or evening.
John Hasse: In one of the black churches.
John Hasse: And I had never… been to a prayer meeting. I was raised Methodist, then Unitarian.
John Hasse: And I'd never been to a permeating, I'd never even heard of a permeating.
John Hasse: But, they were about… 15… People mostly… women.
John Hasse: We sat down on the floor, Very ragged circle.
John Hasse: And… After some prompt from the preacher, People begin praying.
John Hasse: Oh, wow.
John Hasse: And… Help my herman. Thank you, Jesus.
John Hasse: Things like that, and I didn't follow up.
John Hasse: the parishioners… with any questions, because I thought that would have been prying.
John Hasse: I wasn't going to put them on the spot, or make them feel uncomfortable, or anything like that.
John Hasse: But, no, I don't recall that, Dawson Talked with us about… Ethics.
John Hasse: Or… As one would today, getting permission.
John Hasse: The others… said they didn't get permission, and then I didn't. I don't recall.
John Hasse: having to get permission. I mean, today, of course, wouldn't dream of…
John Hasse: Recording somebody without permission, but back then, that was… That was a different time.
Julie Stout: Which is why I thought of it as a question to ask, because I was curious to know
Julie Stout: if the project did handle it in a way that we would consider, like, ethical, or, what other ways was it handled? So… and no other student that I've talked to so far has said they needed, like, written permission or anything like that, similar to you.
John Hasse: a… it wasn't… That we were being unethical. It was that this…
John Hasse: Wasn't an issue at the time.
John Hasse: Field workers, generally used to ask people if they'd Sit for an interview, or… There we go.
John Hasse: Performance could be… recorded, and… It was much less…
John Hasse: What did you time back then?
Julie Stout: I definitely understand.
Julie Stout: This might feed into your own stories and anecdotes, but I was wondering if you experienced any quote-unquote pivotal events or decisions that shaped the project's direction, or your own, outlook on how you want to conduct fieldwork and document the community.
John Hasse: Hmm.
John Hasse: You know, if I hadn't… Taken that course in field work.
John Hasse: And I believe it was from Henry Classy, the… legendary folklorist at IU.
John Hasse: I don't think I would have been selected.
John Hasse: Join the so-called Gary Game.
John Hasse: And so that was… that was a very formative experience when I… Tiptoed into this,
John Hasse: church on the west side of Bloomington.
John Hasse: I was feeling so shy and conspicuous, and I just kind of tried to shrink down my body, and I…
John Hasse: Tiptoed in and sat down in the back row.
John Hasse: there may be… 10 rows of, church pews.
John Hasse: Is the only white person in the church.
John Hasse: I sat down, Kind of trying to hunch down.
John Hasse: And the preacher, I, Tall, stout woman,
John Hasse: saw me immediately. I wasn't fooling her or anybody else, she said.
John Hasse: Come on out front, brother. The back row is for the back sliders.
John Hasse: So… So… No.
John Hasse: No choice but to comply.
John Hasse: I went up to the front row, and, afterwards,
John Hasse: Some of the congregants gathered in a circle, And…
John Hasse: Began praying, and then speaking in tongues.
John Hasse: And I'd never… Experienced? Witnessed?
John Hasse: Anything like that.
John Hasse: To my great surprise, After a while?
John Hasse: I was speaking in tongues, too.
John Hasse: And… I don't know whether it was,
John Hasse: The Spirit got hold of me, or…
John Hasse: I was just… unintentionally following the example of the people around me. It never happened again.
John Hasse: But it was, these experiences at this church.
John Hasse: we're really… formative. They asked me to…
John Hasse: play the piano, and I did, they…
John Hasse: Even though I didn't think I was…
John Hasse: Very good at all. They said, well, you're the best pianists we've ever had. Would you please accompany the choir every Sunday? We have a radio broadcast.
John Hasse: And… you know, I was so… Honored when she asked me.
John Hasse: But, tell you.
John Hasse: The work is just piled on.
John Hasse: graduate students, at the time, and I, I… I… I couldn't…
John Hasse: I couldn't make the time, so I had to… Politely thank her and decline.
John Hasse: But those were… those were the formative experiences that set me up for the 6 weeks in Gary.
Julie Stout: Are there any other, stories or anecdotes you'd like to share of your time, doing the work?
Julie Stout: For the Gary Project.
John Hasse: Hmm…
Julie Stout: Anything that comes to mind?
John Hasse: It was a corny joke, you'd call it a dad joke, that… Richard Dawson told.
John Hasse: after, I think after we were there, maybe it was during the time we were there, that
John Hasse: Joe worked.
John Hasse: many, many years at the U.S. Steel Plant.
John Hasse: And finally, his… 65th… 65th birthday came around, and… He had to retire.
John Hasse: Every day when Joe left the… plant.
John Hasse: The guard stopped him because Joe was pushing a covered wheelbarrow.
John Hasse: And every day, The guard lifted the tarp and looked inside.
John Hasse: And it was empty.
John Hasse: Day after day, day after day.
John Hasse: Wheelbarrow was always empty.
John Hasse: And so finally, on Joe's last day, the guard says, Hey, Joe.
John Hasse: Every day you've been going out here with a wheelbarrow, and I look inside, there's nothing in it.
John Hasse: What have you been stealing? And Joe says, Wheelbarrows.
John Hasse: So, that's one thing I remember about Dawson, and… I remember one night.
John Hasse: I think we were on the campus of… Indiana University Northwest.
John Hasse: And… We had to go from…
John Hasse: cars to a building, or from one building to the other. I just remember it was a…
John Hasse: Partially moonlit night.
John Hasse: Probably 9 o'clock at night.
John Hasse: Mostly dark.
John Hasse: And… Dawson started running.
John Hasse: And… You know, he wasn't in great shape.
John Hasse: And he had lots of heart problems.
John Hasse: His tongue was practically hanging out of his mouth like a…
John Hasse: Like a, tired dog might do.
John Hasse: And I remember being really worried that Grief, should he be running?
John Hasse: You could get another heart attack.
John Hasse: He was a man who… Almost single-handedly made folklore a respected, academic discipline.
John Hasse: And, did much… Much for the discipline. He was also the… Chair of…
John Hasse: I don't know the number, but it could have been over a hundred.
John Hasse: doctoral dissertations at Indiana University. He always wanted to be the chair of the committee, even though it wasn't his area of expertise. So, he was the chair of my committee, which had to do with ragtime, which he knew nothing about.
John Hasse: The advisor was Ruth Stone, the ethnomusicologist.
John Hasse: But, I remember he pushed himself so hard.
John Hasse: It is writing.
John Hasse: And during the Gary project, I saw more examples of that.
John Hasse: And I had to feel sorry for his wife.
John Hasse: I suspect she was long-suffering, that…
John Hasse: Long hours at the office, probably worked all weekend on his next book, whatever it was.
John Hasse: And… I learned from that. I learned that, you know, You can have… A great career, You can have…
John Hasse: Great health, And you can have… a great… Marriage, relationship.
John Hasse: But it's very, very, very difficult to have all three.
John Hasse: And I suspect, in Dawson's case, The work came first, and…
John Hasse: Marriage.
John Hasse: wasn't that important, and I don't… I didn't see any evidence that he took care of himself by…
John Hasse: going to the gym or anything, so I worried about him, and…
John Hasse: A couple years after I left IU, in fact, he did pass away.
John Hasse: I'm guessing of a heart attack.
John Hasse: So that was, he was a… he was a positive example in many ways for lots of
John Hasse: aspiring scholars, but this was one way in which I felt
John Hasse: At least for me, he was a negative example.
Julie Stout: And you saw that firsthand working with him on this project, I'm sure.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Are there any other anecdotes you'd like to share before I move on to this next question?
John Hasse: Hmm… Nothing leaps to mind, Julie, but,
John Hasse: Think in the back of my brain about it.
Julie Stout: just think at the back of your brain, while I keep… I only have a few more here for this section, so no worries to keep thinking.
Julie Stout: This one's kind of an interesting one, but which materials, whether that be photos or recordings or documents, would you highlight for preservation? And where do you know that they are housed, if you do know?
John Hasse: Well, I took, dozens of rolls of film.
John Hasse: I think they're mostly black and white.
John Hasse: They were all 35mm.
John Hasse: There were some color.
John Hasse: Pictures.
John Hasse: Because I have a color snapshot.
John Hasse: A group of steelworkers, Gathered on a weekend on a street corner, Singing Dua.
John Hasse: Unaccompanied doo-op.
John Hasse: So there were some color photos.
John Hasse: And… I took, I shot dozens of videotapes.
John Hasse: And dozens of audio tapes.
John Hasse: And… I don't have the details in front of me, but… I'm very concerned that,
John Hasse: And I tried to track some of these down a couple years ago, Nobody could find them.
John Hasse: And I'm very, very worried that this material, that somebody… Threw it out.
John Hasse: I hope that's not the case, but I was so incensed, I was ready to write the president of the university.
John Hasse: I still might. I don't know. I just can't understand why.
John Hasse: Why it can't be found.
Julie Stout: And that was to deposit them to IU Bloomington, and not Northwest, correct?
John Hasse: Right.
Julie Stout: Right.
John Hasse: If memory serves, and it might not… In this case.
John Hasse: the… videotapes…
John Hasse: were at the Folklore Institute.
John Hasse: And the audio tapes went to the archives of traditional music.
John Hasse: I've forgotten where the… photograph, negatives and slides went probably to the Folklore Institute as well.
Julie Stout: Those, I think… I remember some of your photographs being in IU Archives.
Julie Stout: at this point, but I'm currently working through Archives of Traditional Music videos.
Julie Stout: And so, I can also let you know if I find them. Because at this… up to the point where I was inquiring about them, they had not been described or published or anything, and so…
Julie Stout: I'm the one describing and publishing them. And so, if I see anything, I can let you know for sure.
John Hasse: Thank you very much.
Julie Stout: But you, yeah, you put many hours into your work, and…
Julie Stout: took great care in trying to make sure that you did it justice, and so I understand why you would want it to be… to know where it's housed currently, so…
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: I definitely understand.
Julie Stout: Okay, this one's kind of… this next question feeds into what you mentioned before, because I know Richard and Richard March and Inta Carpenter touch heavily on the struggles with, the technology.
Julie Stout: the video cameras, the, this giant equipment, giant heavy equipment that none of you guys have worked with before, presumably. And maybe this is the same for you, but what was your biggest challenge, and toughest hurdles to overcome, and how were they addressed?
John Hasse: Well, I'd had some experience with these still cameras.
John Hasse: And some experience with a… portable.
John Hasse: high quality, Audio tape recorder.
John Hasse: Reel to reel.
John Hasse: the two… brands that… If the musicologists would use in the field were…
John Hasse: At that time, I believe, Nagra, N-A-G-R-A.
John Hasse: or UHER, U-H-E-R, which is probably a…
John Hasse: German, but could have been a Swiss or Austrian company.
John Hasse: I think.
John Hasse: We had a… Here. Nagas were more expensive, but, marvelous technology for the time.
John Hasse: The video camera was a challenge.
John Hasse: And it was clunky.
John Hasse: It's shot only in black and white, the tape was…
John Hasse: Maybe it was an inch wide, it was a… A format that's long since Gone obsolete.
John Hasse: And it didn't always work.
John Hasse: It was also kind of heavy, and lugging.
John Hasse: These three things around.
John Hasse: At the same time, was a lot. It was very awkward and heavy, and… Fragile.
John Hasse: So that was… that was just the bulk and, weight of them.
John Hasse: Presented a challenge.
Julie Stout: Any other… oh, sorry.
John Hasse: Yeah, sorry. The editing of the videotape was another challenge. I mean,
John Hasse: I had worked in the archives of traditional music as a… research assistant.
John Hasse: And I learned how to… Edit and splice audio tape.
John Hasse: Back then, we had a razor blade, a little cutting block.
John Hasse: You make a diagonal cut in the tape.
John Hasse: And then you… we had some adhesive tape that would tape the two… pieces of… Videotaped together.
John Hasse: You couldn't do that with the videotape.
John Hasse: And so… I don't recall.
John Hasse: exactly how I managed to make this 30-minute documentary, because it had
John Hasse: 8, 10 different clips in it, and… As I recall, it's fairly… continuous, there's not…
John Hasse: 5 seconds of dead screen between the various segments.
John Hasse: But it was… it was not easy, that's for sure.
Julie Stout: The technology continues to be one of the biggest things that the students have said that they struggled with.
Julie Stout: Was there anything else that comes to mind for any challenges that you had to overcome through your time?
John Hasse: Oh, well, I've touched on, the… incredible loss I was feeling.
John Hasse: Because of the death of my mother, I would say, Fatigue,
John Hasse: Man, I could have used some downtime then, I… I mean… I, you know, if… If a, wise.
John Hasse: Man, or a… excellent,
John Hasse: psychotherapist could have come into my life at that time, told me what to do, I'm sure they would have said.
John Hasse: John, you need some downtime. You've been through a… Traumatic loss.
John Hasse: And, you just need to…
John Hasse: Time for yourself to start healing.
John Hasse: And I didn't get that at all.
John Hasse: with the Gary Project.
John Hasse: It was a challenge constantly, because I was constantly doing Unfamiliar, new things.
John Hasse: you know, Gary and the surrounding area was totally…
John Hasse: new to me, Terra Incognita, as I said, and…
John Hasse: I have to improvise constantly. What do I say to this preacher?
John Hasse: how do I approach this singing group, you know?
John Hasse: Where should I set up my mic? Where should I set up the camera?
John Hasse: How long should I stay?
John Hasse: Is there anything I can do to help these folks who've been helpful to me?
John Hasse: if the project were today, I would think that the… Director would have.
John Hasse: asked the NEH.
John Hasse: For money to compensate the informants.
John Hasse: Because some of these people were taking time off from their work.
John Hasse: They could be rehearsing, they could have been doing a gig, perhaps.
John Hasse: And I felt bad at the time that we had no money to give anybody.
John Hasse: And there was a… a group of…
John Hasse: I think it was 4 singers.
John Hasse: And they model themselves after
John Hasse: The Barrett sisters.
John Hasse: And they sang a couple songs for me, and I recorded it.
John Hasse: And then… I heard what I'm saying.
John Hasse: Not to me, but to the other ones. That's enough.
John Hasse: Like, you know… We shouldn't be giving our way… our…
John Hasse: Art and our music without compensation, and… I felt bad again.
John Hasse: But that wasn't… part of the project, I had…
John Hasse: Not a penny to give anybody.
Julie Stout: I think that also feeds into, like, maybe ethical considerations as well, in terms of…
Julie Stout: understand that people are giving their time, their effort, and, experiences and voice to you as well. And so, I think it feeds into that.
John Hasse: Yeah, and… The next time, I had an opportunity.
John Hasse: to… Set up the rules for an oral history project.
John Hasse: Which was… In about 1990, when I was at the Smithsonian.
John Hasse: we re-established the Smithsonian Jazz Oral History Project, or program.
John Hasse: And I insisted.
John Hasse: That we not only compensate the interviewers, But the interviewees.
John Hasse: Because these people were tradition bearers, very valuable with all the knowledge and experience.
John Hasse: Wisdom they have to share.
John Hasse: And… Their time was at least as valuable as the…
John Hasse: Scholars and writers we hired to do the interviews.
John Hasse: And so we… calculated the… the, price… Or the income that, Professional jazz musician.
John Hasse: Would make, in, say, 3 or 4 hour period.
John Hasse: as if they were doing a gig, and that's what we offered them, and I felt… Very good about.
Julie Stout: I think it's interesting that you kind of,
Julie Stout: just mention, I'm like, what would you do now? And I think that feeds in, like, wonderfully into how you were able to actually compensate people in your own project in the future, and keep that in mind, and for consideration as well.
Julie Stout: Did you get anything as a graduate student from this? Was this part of your, like, appointment, or was it, like, a part-time thing, or…
John Hasse: I don't think I've got any academic credit.
Julie Stout: Right.
John Hasse: Certainly, our expenses paid,
John Hasse: We stayed at the red… in.
John Hasse: in Merrillville, Indiana.
John Hasse: It was, pretty low budget.
John Hasse: But it was convenient. I think most of us were there.
John Hasse: So, our expenses were paid.
John Hasse: And we must have gotten some kind of stipend. I mean, nothing…
John Hasse: We could get rich on, or even pay a semester's tuition with, but…
John Hasse: There must have been some kind of stipend.
Julie Stout: That was just a follow-up on your compensation question and point.
Julie Stout: So this is a final question for you regarding the Doris and Gary project. It's regarding your… the impact, legacy, and your reflection on it.
Julie Stout: What lasting impacts stand out for participants, IU, and the field, and what lessons or advice would you pass on to future stewards?
John Hasse: Could you repeat the question, please?
Julie Stout: Yeah, of course.
Julie Stout: What lasting impacts stand out about the project? For the participants, for IU, and the field itself? And what lessons or advice would you pass on to people who… for future stewards, for people who want to conduct work like this in the future? And for people who want to care for the collection?
John Hasse: Impacts.
John Hasse: I think you'd have to track down the informants.
John Hasse: And ask them if it made any difference to them at all.
John Hasse: I don't remember whether Any of the…
John Hasse: Results, or you could say end products, of the Gary Project, wherever
John Hasse: Taken back to the region and presented To the public there.
John Hasse: You'd think… You'd think that Dawson would have done that, but I just…
John Hasse: I don't believe that I went back.
John Hasse: So, this may have been a… just a… Momentary blip.
John Hasse: for most… of the informants.
John Hasse: It's very possible they never heard of Dortson, or…
John Hasse: or the Gary Project, or any of the people in it, again, that's one of the regrets.
John Hasse: that I have when I… Go out into the field.
John Hasse: Which I often did in my job at the Smithsonian.
John Hasse: And I get to meet these wonderful people.
John Hasse: And they're generous, they give of their time, They're bright, they're interesting.
John Hasse: And I go back… You know, enriched.
John Hasse: But… there isn't the time, or I didn't make the time, Jeez.
John Hasse: Build a long-term friendship, to stay in touch with them.
John Hasse: And… you know, if I had.
John Hasse: I would have had a lot less time to go out and meet.
John Hasse: more people than I needed to.
John Hasse: You know, collect from.
John Hasse: So… In that sense, it was a blip for me, since I…
John Hasse: I don't think I had any…
John Hasse: communication with any of the people that I worked with again.
John Hasse: I did… Put together a little audio sampler.
John Hasse: And I sent it to Moses Ash, Who is the founder and… Owner of Folkways Records.
John Hasse: In New York City, legendary company that issued Folk and world music.
John Hasse: And I was proposing to him, LP of Gospel and Gary.
John Hasse: And he wrote right back, yes, let's do it!
John Hasse: But I was… I was just swamped with,
John Hasse: my dissertation and everything else, and I didn't pursue it.
John Hasse: If I had, of course, I would have gone back to… The people on the recording.
John Hasse: Track them all down.
John Hasse: asked their permission and gotten it in writing, and if there was any money coming from Folkways.
John Hasse: Would have wanted to share it with them.
John Hasse: But that didn't happen.
John Hasse: So… Impact on me, I think it made me a better cultural worker.
John Hasse: You know, when you're… When you're working across cultures.
John Hasse: When you're bridging cultures, or people are bridging cultures to you.
John Hasse: As some of my, informant's work?
John Hasse: You've got to… Maximize your sensitivity.
John Hasse: You've got to listen very carefully.
John Hasse: You have to… S?
John Hasse: Ask yourself, Are you really… How sincere you are.
John Hasse: You have to be your authentic self. You can't be a phony in any way.
John Hasse: And you have to look out.
John Hasse: Not just for… What's going to be deposited?
John Hasse: But for these people's… feelings, and…
John Hasse: You know, if they're professionals for their livelihood, you can't… You can't leave any damage.
John Hasse: You have to go into this kind of fieldwork with it.
John Hasse: Saying the Hippocratic oath of fieldwork.
John Hasse: To yourself. First, do no harm.
John Hasse: You've got to realize that you are…
John Hasse: There is an ambassador of Indiana University.
John Hasse: Even though nobody appointed you an ambassador, you don't have that title.
John Hasse: But people know you as a representative of the university.
John Hasse: So you've got to be on your very best behavior.
John Hasse: Because you are representing the university.
John Hasse: And that's very important.
John Hasse: So keep that in mind.
John Hasse: It broadened my interest in Gospel music, and… When that preacher said, Complimented me on my playing.
John Hasse: That added a special kind of…
John Hasse: Spark to my fuel.
John Hasse: My passion was… Even in graduate school, I think.
John Hasse: to… Build a career.
John Hasse: that worked.
John Hasse: Hard.
John Hasse: To help.
John Hasse: Black, music, and jazz find a place of… More respect in our society.
John Hasse: So I think that… that helped fuel that.
John Hasse: Ed, what was the second part of your question?
Julie Stout: First I had, your… the lasting impact on IU in the field, and then it would be, what advice would you give? Which I think you actually started that a little bit, and, like, spoke on that wonderfully, so…
John Hasse: Okay, lasting impact.
John Hasse: I think you'd probably have to talk to some… Young folklorists today who are…
John Hasse: into American and regional folklore to ask them if they think it has had any impact on the work. In fact, I would…
John Hasse: Highly recommend that. Not…
John Hasse: necessarily graduate students, but people who've been out in the field as full-time professionals for a few years. You could ask graduate students, too, if they've heard of it, but…
John Hasse: I think they would be a much better judge than I.
John Hasse: Of its lasting impact.
John Hasse: And what further advice would I give to people
John Hasse: You're talking about graduate students from IU going into the field?
Julie Stout: Let's say advice for field workers?
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: Yeah, let's stick with advice for field workers, future field workers, which are typically graduate students who are studying to do that.
John Hasse: Well, besides, what I just spoke about a few minutes ago, remind yourself.
John Hasse: That it's good.
John Hasse: To get out of the… out in the field.
John Hasse: Get off your butt.
John Hasse: Leave your computer behind.
John Hasse: And go talk to real people.
John Hasse: And especially… Listen to them.
John Hasse: Listening is more important than talking.
John Hasse: You know, I like to say, nobody can… you can't learn anything if you're running your mouth.
John Hasse: And I think… Way too many people.
John Hasse: Are more interested in talking, Usually about themselves.
John Hasse: But they're more interested in talking than listening and learning.
John Hasse: And so, that might be… the number one.
John Hasse: Lesson, I would impart.
John Hasse: Listen.
John Hasse: Closely.
John Hasse: In fact, I think that's a powerful lesson.
John Hasse: every professional Everybody in a relationship, could… could use. Listen closely.
John Hasse: if you… if somebody that you knew, Julie, was going Go to Gary.
John Hasse: Now, I know it's…
John Hasse: This city has lost a lot of population in the last 50 years, and I feel just terrible for it.
John Hasse: This is the city where the Jackson family came from, the Jackson 5,
John Hasse: City of a lot of good people.
John Hasse: A lot of good churches.
John Hasse: good music.
John Hasse: You know, and I just feel bad that… been…
John Hasse: Depopulating. I just feel bad, but… You know, maybe there's a… a new… Project to be,
John Hasse: built around the Calumet region, and… compared… Compare it with…
John Hasse: what Dawson's project yielded, and see
John Hasse: what the changes are, I could see that would make a very… Interesting project book.
John Hasse: Maybe documentary?
John Hasse: Maybe track down some of those informants.
John Hasse: 50 years ago, they'd have to be… and they're…
John Hasse: At the time, they would have to have been No more than, I suppose, 35 years old.
John Hasse: But they're… they're… There are probably some still around.
John Hasse: It'd be an interesting project for somebody.
Julie Stout: That was,
Julie Stout: when I was configuring my final project, that was a topic of discussion to see if we could do that.
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: The sleuthing to find these people is a bit tough, and like you said, some of them have sadly passed away, but there are some, like, descendants that
Julie Stout: like, still are around and everything, and so there's some connections that are maybe… maybe to be made for… in the future for that, so… which is interesting in itself.
Julie Stout: But…
Julie Stout: Unless you have anything else, which you are totally free to say anything else you'd like for this section, otherwise that ends our… this…
Julie Stout: Second part of the oral histories.
John Hasse: Gosh, you've been so thorough, Julie.
John Hasse: I… I'm not sure I can think of anything else to add.
John Hasse: I'm so glad that you're talking to
John Hasse: Tom Adler, and that you've spoken with Richard March.
John Hasse: Please give… Tom, my very best, and Richard, if you communicate with him again.
John Hasse: Again, very sorry we lost Adrian Seward.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
John Hasse: It was, as I think back on the memory, it was a shining…
John Hasse: difficult, but shining bright spot in my life, and I'm…
John Hasse: Grateful to have been part of that project.
Julie Stout: I think that's a wonderful way to end this last, this next section, and I will go into the next one, so let me end this here.